when i was actually applying to  hillsdale the whip program was a major  factor in wanting to come to hostel in  the first place i'm an editorial intern  so every day i post our websites videos  i write posts about foreign policy  things that are going on on the hill  especially from the journalism  perspective it's a unique city to be in  because we have congress and we have the  white house so it's a really unique  opportunity to actually go to events  where news is happening  i think one of the best parts about  being on whip during the semester as  opposed to being a summer is that you  get to take classes with hillsdale  professors you learn so much  i would definitely say that the time  spent in washington dc with the whip  program is definitely worth it you still  do have a community of hillsdale  students in the area i mean it's really  easy to keep up with your friends with  skype and facebook and twitter so i  would definitely say that the investment  is definitely worth it